[Applause]
[Music]
good evening ladies and gentlemen I'm
Jeremy brought welcome to the sixth and
final event in this year's stunning
series of screenwriters lectures held in
conjunction with Lucie guard and the JJ
Charitable Trust
what can I say about our next speaker
Paul Schrader wrote taxi driver I think
our work here is done
but seriously Paul is so so much more
than the sum of any part that you can
give him in a sentence he is the writer
and co-writer of Raging Bull the Last
Temptation of Christ American Gigolo
Mishima our life in four chapters
affliction and 2017 s utterly brilliant
disquisition on faith first reformed
Paul has written or directed over 23
extraordinary films and I may well have
got that number wrong to sustain a level
of excellence in this brutal industry
for so many decades to be the
screenwriter of an iconic groundbreaking
film like taxi driver is simply
breathtaking we salute him and we thank
him for taking the time to talk to us
this evening Paul will lecture followed
by a Q&A with film producer Tanya
Circassian after which we will as we
always do open it up to questions from
the floor
ladies and gentlemen Paul Schrader
is this bike working hear me now before
I begin I'd just like to take a moment
to express my gratitude to someone a
friend and someone who's been in was an
inspiration to me which was Nicolas Roeg
and who had a long and fruitful life and
there's nothing to be sad about and just
what are there was to say acknowledge
you know what he brought to this medium
[Applause]
over the years I have taught a
screenwriting workshop at various places
UCLA Columbia University and what this
lecture is is in fact a summary of that
class it's a prospectus for a course not
given and it's turtle I'll just sort of
take you through the process of the
class because I taught a method of
screenwriting which I devised in fact I
don't think I've ever read a book about
screenwriting and I can't imagine ever
reading one I mean I think one of the
worst things that ever happened to
screening writing is this guy what's his
name Bob
who wrote this book about barbecue per
stack second a couple it doesn't work
that way you know it's not that simple
so I I would take the first class in
which there's an announcement that the
class is open to all who wish to see it
undergraduate or graduate whatever and
so you get a pretty good-sized room
almost as large as this and and you give
an intellectual I mean you give an
introductory lecture and and the
industrial lecture essentially says this
is not an overview of screenwriting this
is my method this is what I have learned
to talk this is what I have taught
myself and the only way to teach
something as trans Punja ball
screenwriting is to teach what has
worked for you because there's no way
you can teach what works for everybody
and and even though what I'm saying may
not work for 75% of you it still has
value because it works for me and so
hopefully your time will be productively
spent and it is also best suited for
first-time writers now this first class
and I say basically art works this is
what I believe I believe art is
functional art is the tool just like a
hammer pliers
I saw you can use it to do stuff
and what you can use it to do is learn
about yourself and learn about other
people and so what I'm going to talk
about is the functionality of
storytelling not just the pleasure of it
or the commerce of it and to understand
how art works you begin with yourself
you are the raw material art isn't
really about anything you're seeing this
about it's about you and this is why
this course is particularly useful for
our first time writers because too many
students look at films and say I can do
a film like that well you probably can't
but why the heck would anybody want to
hire you
they've got people who can do films like
that as proof there are films like that
and they got people who will do it on
command
I'm deadline why would they pull around
with a goofball like you so you start to
think about what is it that I can bring
to the dance
there's no one else can you know what I
walk in the room and say I've got
something of commercial value to you but
it's only my own and if you want it you
have to get it from me so that is ground
zero of the creation of a script I began
writing on a spec meaning speculation
I'm still writing on spec taxi driver
was written on spec first performance
witness
and when you write on spec you are
writing primarily for yourself but
you're also writing a calculation of
what the market place is at any given
time and and so you know that that is a
kind of thing you learn now when you are
the raw material then then you need to
study yourself and in this study will
come this class therefore you know I've
invited you all to the class and thank
you for coming but I can't teach this
many people so there's only going to be
ten of you in the class and I don't
particularly care about getting the ten
most talented students in fact I really
don't care how talented you really are
at all I just want interesting people I
want ten interesting people because I've
got to spend ten two weeks teaching this
class and I want to spend it with ten
interesting people so that the next step
in this class is that everyone who wants
to take the class must write out in no
more than two sentences their most
pressing personal problem at this time
and then I will I will read these
and do you I also want you to include
some basic facts age sex whatever I want
to get a heterogeneous group you know I
don't want ten you know ten white boys
so and but if you and I'll go through
these statements you make I'll go
through them very very quickly and I'll
just go through and pick up ten people
and if you are then invited to the class
your problem then becomes communal
property it is the property of the class
no longer your property if you're not
invited it gets discarded and that for
that reason I want you to write it out
in longhand so that I can actually
discard it so then I get those pieces of
paper and I go through them and if
you've done it a number of times you
start to realize that people fall into
certain categories there's always going
to be the overweight girl usually Jewish
it's always good to be the homosexual
male or female who hasn't told his or
her parents yet there's always going to
be the minority with a huge grudge on
this hilt on the shoulder and there's
always going to be the kid who wants to
kill his father and and so you get
interesting people different kinds of
problems so that you know they're not
all talking about the same problem and
then and you know I tell them that if
you you know we are in the dirty laundry
business this is the business we've
chosen if you have a problem with dirty
laundry you shouldn't be in here and I
don't certainly don't want you in my
class our task is to everybody's
interested in our dirty laundry just not
the way it actually looks
they want it they want us to rework it
and your problem with reworking your
dirty laundry for public consumption you
should not be in this class so now I get
10 students and we have 10 problems and
each student reads his or her statement
and we begin to discuss them
you know the ramifications of this
problem the manifestations what have you
done about it you know who else knows
all this stuff listen to me what you're
doing is group therapy and so I'm going
to do the stages here so we all discuss
these problems what the next class will
bring is a metaphor and begin to discuss
what a metaphor is for your problems a
metaphor is not the same thing as the
problem so using myself as an example I
say you know I did a film about
loneliness about young male loneliness
and this came out of a period of the
dark period of laundry Dan being
ungrounded and I was sort of living in
my car and I had a pain in my stomach
went to the hospital
and a bleeding ulcer at the age of 25
because I was just drinking and driving
and hostel I got this image of the
taxicab it came to me
this yellow rectangular coffin metal
coffin flowing through the open sewers
of a metropolis and inside that coffin
is trapped a young man and it looks like
he's surrounded by life in fact he's
absolutely alone and the power of that
metaphor just overwhelmed me
and I knew I had to write that story
because I was becoming that young man
and the only way I could not become him
was to establish his identity apart from
mine to write about him and so it did I
did and as I said earlier are actually
worse I learned about that young man and
I learned not to be that young man by
writing about it so I walked into the
whole screenwriting business as self
therapy not as commerce and that script
wasn't seen by anybody for a year
afterward it had done its job you know
we went on the shelf so down we need
metaphors for your individual problems
and you need to come back with metaphors
next week now what is a metaphor a
metaphor is the standard it is not the
problem itself so the metaphor for a
lonely boy is not a lonely boy the
metaphor for and unattractive girls not
an unattractive girl it's something like
the metaphor I would like the problem
but not the problem itself it's like two
wires you have the problem in the
metaphor and they have to get close
enough for a spark to jump across and if
they're too far apart
there will be no spark and if they're on
top of each other they'll be
so you have to tease them and play with
the sparks and great stories throughout
history have had great metaphors some of
those famous stories Frankenstein but
you know how can you have a better
metaphor than that the metaphor
essentially does the job you know you
can make or the or the walking zombies
it doesn't really matter how good it is
in before the metaphor has such strength
Jaws Exorcist Rosemary's Baby these are
powerful functional metaphors and and if
you have a good problem and a good
metaphor you know you're a lot of the
battle is won already
the make sure I'm not losing myself here
oh yeah and a metaphor can be sometimes
an occupation taxi driver there could be
a historical moment in time you know
Waterloo I suppose it could be a certain
kind of love story Romeo and Juliet but
it has to be something that expresses
your problem without being the problem
itself and I remember I was teaching
this class at UCLA and I had I was in
analysis at that time in five days a
week unless on the couch and and one of
the things I've been talking with my
psychiatrist about was the inability to
express a lot and now I'm teaching this
class at UCLA and we're in this phase
where we're looking for metaphors and
[Music]
I happened to say to the class member I
said what occupation does this person
have they factory worker a bookkeeper a
doctor
a gigolo a lawyer and boom as soon as I
said the word gigolo I said that's it
boom you've got your metaphor that's the
metaphor you've been looking for for the
inability to express love
now I had a problem now I had a better
for I was on my way sometimes
the metaphor you struggled for it years
later I was looking for a metaphor for
midlife crisis I turned 40 and I was
thinking all right I should do a midlife
movie and I thought about all the normal
stuff
he leaves his wife takes off with a
co-ed by the car drives across country
all these you know joins the Foreign
Service whatever kind of wacky metaphor
they all seem so cliched and so there
was no spark
the wires were right on top of each
other and I began to think well you know
this went out of her only six months I
said well maybe I'm not gonna find a
midlife metaphor and then one night I
woke up abruptly from a dream about 5:00
a.m. and I had been talking in this
dream a drug dealer
I was newton-john it's right in front of
my face just right there and I hadn't
seen him for a year I said oh wow that
was David Wow that was David he was
right in front of me Wow what were we
talking about oh he was asking about me
about the movies you wanted to know what
movies to see him I said that's it I
couldn't find my metaphor and my
metaphor got sick of waiting and
came and found me this middle-aged drug
delivery boy whose boss is quitting it's
a steroid cosmetics company and who has
no skills
that's midlife metaphor right there it
is it's a great one
no one's seen it before and I have my
metaphor and I wouldn't write to my
office and started making notes and by
the end of the day I had tracked down
the real people and and said you know I
want to make a film about you and this
is an aside for the Brits here Cynthia
who was the main drug dealer said to me
well let me get back to you so when she
called me back and she said well I spoke
to Bertolucci I spoke to Jeremy Thomas I
spoke to Michael right and they all say
you're cool so so I did what that was
like sleepers so so the next class
commences and everybody has brought in
several metaphors for their problem and
they propose them for the most part you
know they're very feeble they suffer
from the same problem I had with midlife
crisis just there's no energy in the
metaphor there's no imagination there's
no spark but once they're out there on
the table and once they're part of the
communal discussion you know people
start talking around and and which is
why it's always handy to have a closeted
homosexual in the group because you know
the metaphor that will work for them
which is somebody involved in an
industrial espionage
somebody who is secretly spying on his
own company getting paid by another
company and this is a great metaphor for
a homosexual who hasn't told anybody
because you're actually talking about
the problem without talking about the
problem you know what does it like to
live a double life in which people you
who trust you you are deceiving like any
any spy and so you can say to that
student I said you know here's a try
this metaphor on for size and you know
maybe he doesn't run with it maybe he
does he starts to get the idea of what a
metaphor can do and and then I remember
one class kid had a very interesting
problem which was he had killed somebody
and when he was 16 went in a car and
wasn't his fault but he remembered that
a young fourteen year old child ran out
of the street and obviously that is
something that stayed with you and so we
started trying to come you know what's a
metaphor for that and the metaphor we
came up with going back and forth was a
professional woman in her 30s who had
supposedly an abortion when she was
young but she has now come to realize
that it wasn't an abortion it was a
child that was delivered and went into a
adopted home or whatever in the
marketplace and she because she sees
this girl on the street she said that's
my daughter boom now we're dealing with
the metaphor of a man who killed the kid
because you have the woman seeing the
daughter she killed the daughter is
still alive so that's good to work your
metaphors and then that tap when you
just flip the tables and see it from the
girl's point of view you're in business
the the you know the unattractive or
overweight your own metaphor often you
know that this is a standard one the
ugly duckling was Cinderella or whatever
and it's not terribly constructive for a
young woman who feels herself
unattractive to tell a story about a
woman who feels unattractive it doesn't
she could tell that story but she's not
gonna learn much what she has to do is
put ourselves in the shoes of someone
who thinks they are unattractive
someone who's bulimic come on you know
who is injuring themselves and cutting
themselves because they feel they're
Islands active when they're not no you
know that's a good learning point you
can learn from that and so that's what
we hash out in this third class and try
to get every student headed off at a
certain metaphorical direction the the
the fourth class then revolves around
plot
plot is simply what happens when you
take a medal when you take a problem and
drive it through a metaphor okay you
have a problem a problem is loneliness
you have a metaphoric taxicab driver
shove your problem into the metaphor
what happens well you have a guy who's
drifting around he meets a girl he can't
have but once he meets a girl he wants
but can't have he tries to kill the
father figure of one and fails so he
kills the father figure of the other and
becomes a hero that is the entire plot
Otaki daughter right there and all that
comes from is taking this loneliness and
shoving it through tax account and
imagining what can happen and so the so
you know in this class we explore the
nature of the problem by exploring the
nature of plots what could happen you
know there's only a certain number of
plots out there and but if your problem
is interesting enough if you've analyzed
it properly and if your metaphor is
intriguing enough hackney plots from
yesteryear will live again as you push
them through because they will have a
new life they will be you know the new
wine and the the old bottles and so when
when you start talking about plot you
just hypothesize now
the class is then instructed the next
week to come back with a five to ten
minute narrative of what happens between
their their problem and their metaphor
and the plot but what events can happen
just imagine events come up with
something and it doesn't have to be
qualitative but you but you have to come
up with something and that you know
takes us to the next step I do not
believe that screenwriting is part of
the literary tradition I believe it's
part of the oral tradition it's just me
telling you a story
you know it's your uncle coming back
from a hunting trip and saying you know
the dog ate something bad got sick and
the bird got away and and we didn't come
we didn't you know come back with
anything but if you're up goes a good
storyteller hopefully he is I had I am
good storytellers he can tell that story
you know for 15 minutes and that's what
it is our world traditions let me tell
you stories so now we have these 10
students each of whom has a little bit
of a story to tell and they're just
exploring and let me it's temporary near
eyes okay so okay
a man is giving a lecture at BAFTA
wearing a blue jumper in the middle of
the lecture he has orange glasses nobody
knows why
in the middle of lecture he improperly
walks out and leaves without comment and
on the street someone tracked him down
and says you know what's wrong what's
wrong wrong he said I just got scared I
got scared they said well you know let's
have a drink ok ok we'll have a drink
and he said I don't drink but if you
come to my flat I got some pot it's ok
ok that sounds good so he goes over
there in an hour he and the two
flatmates are all smoking pot I'm making
literally making this up as I speak so
now I've got this older man these two
kids smoking grass hit a flat and the
story is starting to feel a little thin
and you know when Raymond Chandler once
said you know if you get in trouble I
have somebody walk in the room with a
gun because the reader will be so happy
they're there they won't ask how they
got there
and so now I'm in a little trouble so ok
a red sports car pulls up and two huge
Bachmann 300 pounds each like
linebackers wearing purple suits are
sitting in the car
they screech to a halt they get out and
go toward the apartment well I got you
back what do I got you back down you
know you're all on the edge of your
seats I also got these two black guys
and purple suits and I have to figure
out what to do with them but maybe
hopefully something will come to me and
that's what storytelling is and the
first time you tell your story
it may be 5-10 minutes long and you kind
of make it up a bit as you go you say to
somebody let me buy your coffee let me
buy you a drink I got a how are you here
is the story
and you don't really care what they
think of the story it doesn't really
matter whether you like it or not what
matters is the level of attention they
are paying you do you have them what is
the eye contact what is the body
language you can feel it when you don't
have somebody and then you gotta
improvise just like a stand-up comic and
you got to keep them you know and maybe
when you realize in the back of your
head is that I'm doing too much
acquisition I should have had a comic
scene in here you know if I had told
comic scene right there I could have
kept them but now it was just just too
much exposition so you're making these
calculations and you're making notes as
you tell story and then you out like
tell surrogate outline tell story get
and it grows in length and if you can
tell a story for 45 minutes you have a
movie and the way to know for sure if
you're uncertain is take someone to a
pub and start telling your story and
then about you know 30 minutes into your
story you say excuse me I have to go the
bathroom and you come back and you start
another conversation another tangent
maybe talking politics now if they don't
ask you how the story ends you don't
have a story and this is actually I
think a very very productive way to
develop a story not that you know often
stories fall into three acts of sewing
life tends to be you know past present
future but it doesn't have to be three
acts some stories are 2x some stories on
what Aksum are five it will find its own
shape and it'll find it as you tell the
story and what begins to happen as you
tell your story repeatedly
arie outline it one of them two things
happens and they're both good things one
is you get sick of the story it dies it
withers and you walk away this is a very
good thing it means you have just saved
yourself six months of writing a story
that nobody wants to read or make you
it's a good thing that happened to you
you've protected yourself because
there's nothing that's quite so
debilitating as writing three or four
scripts in a row as a beginning writer
and none of them people are interested
in your darling your spirit is broken so
don't even write until you know
somebody's gonna be interested in that
story the other thing that can happen
while you tell the story is the story
will get sick of being told you feel it
as you tell the story the story will
start saying to you I want to be written
now I'm done with this phase
I'm fully formed I want to go into print
and that's also a happy day because
there you are with a fully fleshed story
in your head full of dialogue Pacey's
and everything and you can go to work so
what exists between the oral tradition
and the script phase is the outlines
and I've brought some outlines to show
you and our line begins you know just as
a list of things and in a given film
[Applause]
usually about 40 to 50 things happen so
as you tell your story your outline
expands so maybe it begins with 15
things that happened or 20 things and
gradually expands and that's always the
best way to write you're much more
creative when you're going larger the
worst thing to do for me as a writer is
to start with 150 pages and figure out
how you can do 100 I'd rather start with
70 and figure out how I can do 100 so
here are my outlines from so those are
the outlines from American Gigolo they
actually the ones I was using and you
can see this is an earlier outline and
I'm the outline I mean note to myself
add something at 16 at something that 12
reversed these two scenes move this
scene over here and so I'm reworking my
outline and then I will tell it again
and then we working again
and until you get to this level of
outline which is pretty close to what
you need when you need to start writing
and that is a list of everything that
happens and it's also a list of a
projected page count
so let me see here okay something okay
Julian and Leroy scene 42 happens on
page 102 I'm done I'm doing a running
page color so I can tell you what
happens 102 minutes if you're using the
page a minute I can tell you what
happens a hundred two minutes into a
film and that is because film is a fixed
time frame and a scene that is good on
page 35 and it's not necessarily going
on 45 same thing you know and so you
have to be very aware of the calibration
of your time it's like a long-distance
runner who's running along it says you
know when I when I pass the coffee shop
I should be 12 minutes 30 seconds into
the run and if I'm too quick
I should evaluate where I am I only 12
minutes into the run or if I'm 13
minutes and why am i slow calculating
saving heavens you're ready to script
I'm five pages off my outline was my
calculation wrong in which case I need
to recalculate or am I just adding stuff
that's unnecessary and so you're always
thinking about that and and so
here's a this is from Raging Bull now
you can see here I okay
Danville like I predicted it to be on
page 77 I predicted it to last two and a
half pages it fell in at 74 so I was in
my parameters you know I was hitting my
mile markers and and then as I and I
like to do these outlines I'm a single
sheet because you can carry it around
with you and you can look at it so
here's the Last Temptation of Christ
you know the entire film on a single
sheet of paper every scene the length of
every scene the projection of every
scene and then when the scene is crossed
out list of what the real page count was
so if I projected Jesus scourged by
Pilate I projected it an 81 that came in
85 okay so and so that just like
storytelling is spontaneous it's also
extremely calculated and so how do you
get from that spontaneous moment in the
coffee shop where you're literally
making stuff up through that calculation
where you know what's going to happen on
page 84 well you do it through the
outline and then you read outline back
and forth and usually it's usually about
and in terms of a detailed outline maybe
four or five of them I do before I'm
that point where you know ready to be
written and and and sometimes you get
very complex you're making notes all
over the place there's light sleeper so
that more or less completes that more or
less completes the process so we are now
six classes it out of ten and the
students are now permitted to write and
they have to have a script done in ten
weeks
obviously none of them are gonna do this
and so the script you know strangle and
over the next year or so but I don't
want to let them write till we get to
this point so now they're writing and I
fill out the remainder of the class with
some exercises I'll do an exposition
exercise I'll do a dialogue exercise and
then I'll have a class about formatting
and more or less technical things and
then the last class I always like to
bring in a fellow screenwriter who works
in a method totally unlike mine and who
for whom everything I have said is wrong
and inappropriate and I just Brianna
Brianna see I've been convincing you of
something for ten weeks here's a working
screenwriter who happens to be even
wealthier than I am
and he doesn't believe a word I've said
so just bear that in mind as you move on
in life and I guess that you know and
usually in every class there's usually
one script that actually gets made
strangely enough remember I had a
student and I had UCLA he was a Japanese
student Nisei and he was trying to write
about his family and everything about it
was so happy to just so predictable in
her family dynamics and in the yelling
times that boring there was an article
about the lowriders the the car the car
club gangs in East LA and it's very
fascinating and I said to him Desmond
Nakano is still is a working writer and
I said you know go go down there hang
out with those guys you know what's
gonna happen you tell me you're still 90
yeah interesting and write a script
about what they do
what's the worst that can happen they
tell you to [ __ ] off that's all go give
it a shot that's my assignment to you
don't come back next week if you haven't
so he goes down there any first meeting
these guys and I was hanging with him
and they take him it sort of into their
social lives and he starts writing a
script about that well if the same
script he was trying to write about his
parents and his brother and his sister
only now he was far enough away from it
that he wasn't getting locked up he was
freed and everything he wanted to say
about his immediate situation he was
able to say about this metaphorical
situation and and you know that usually
in every class you lose somebody who it
works for then of course
just mentioned there's always a fair
number who doesn't work for us but at
least a hopefully they've learned
something and I was proud to keep it to
45 minutes I didn't quite make it but I
once gave this lecture in New Delhi
three hours
thank you I was just thanking Paul for
the brilliant lecture and also letting
you know that the clip you just just saw
on the screen there is a script it's a
clip from Paul's latest feature film
first reformed and I'm going to take the
opportunity to talk to him about both
the lecture and first reformed if I can
and there will be a chance for you to
also ask questions Paul what you haven't
talked about in your lecture there is
three or four of the other things that I
always think a really important for
screenwriters
to tackle tone dialogue character and
endings and I wondered if I might ask
you about all of those well
dialogue when I after I finished the
billion section we get into these we do
a one class of dialogue and I give an
example I say okay magazine a
supermarket he meets his ex-wife she has
a young child or no man maybe not that
maybe two people waiting for a subway a
mother and a daughter and this is sort
of what they talk about right some
dialogue for me and everybody comes in
with dialogue and I every time people
dialogue usually doesn't work because
it's so linear and the mind is not
necessarily engaged by linear dialogue
and what I often do at that point is I
instruct class members to read the scene
first we read it through then we read it
through backwards last line first second
to last line second to third life in
Reverse so that the questions the
answers are appearing before the
questions that's always more interesting
and you know students begin to sort of
understand you know Harold Pinter's
thesis which is you know language is the
tool we use not to come
okay and there's a language also does
that so I do that with dialogue and then
I also do it with exposition which is
always such a killer give an
expositional exercise that is impossible
you know and see how people get around
it the end I always know the end I can't
start a script unless I know the title
and the end yes you know the idea of
somebody could write the scripts and not
have a title for yet just I can't
imagine it and I've noticed with your
titles you often keep the character out
its first reformed taxi driver you don't
I think you once said of Brussels and
pickpocket it isn't a pickpocket its
pickpocket and I wondered if you could
talk a little bit about why you choose
to do that well I mean well you know
what title has to have a certain
resonance in a certain mystery to it I
hate to run the tip titles Breaking Away
running home oh that's terrible and also
needs to have preferably a consonant in
it I have one hard sounded can arrest
the progress so you don't it's not at
all soft sobs um yeah I am I was just
working on a script I'm now abandoned it
but I I couldn't think of a good type
and then I came up with a title but I
had nothing to do with the script at all
it was called this birding wheel and but
still didn't work I gave up
and you don't start without the ending I
think probably because looking at your
body of work the ending is always
rumination or a mediation on some form
of redemption in the broadest and
loosest sense of the word is that is
that part of why you write a pair of
what why you write is that part of why
you tell stories I'm not quite sure why
I tell stories and I'm not sure if I
were 18 years old now I would tell
stories you know it was a time in a
place and it seems to be a thing to do
maybe I should be writing code if I was
in my teens but this idea that are
dysfunctional then it has that it can
get you through life they can make you
learn and they can make you survive and
you know and at any point in all our
lives we have two or three problems that
are running around whether it's problems
about relationships or sexual needs or
career crisis whatever there's something
going on and so you're always floating
around sort of looking for metaphors and
sometimes they arrive and sometimes they
don't
but I think when you started writing it
was a time when cinema afforded the
opportunity for people to have answered
the questions that were in the ether and
somehow they looked to the big screen to
address those questions I wonder if you
would agree with that and whether well
you know there are people who talked
about the American cinema of the 70s as
some healthy young period it was to a
degree but not because there were any
more talented filmmakers there's
probably in fact more talented
filmmakers today than there was in the
70s but there was in the seventies was
better audiences and a lot of what was
happening in the world had people in
consternation women's rights gay rights
sexual liberation drug liberation
anti-war all of these things were
rolling on top of each other and people
were turning to the Arts
so cynically movies what should we feel
about this Baba Ted and Alice about
wife-swapping coming home about Vietnam
veterans or unmarried women about female
liberation
so almost one a week films were coming
out to address these things that were on
people's minds and when when people take
movies seriously it's very easy to make
a serious movie when they don't take it
seriously it's very very hard
we now have audiences that don't take
movies seriously it's very hard to make
a serious movie for them so it's not
that our filmmakers are letting you down
it's you audiences are letting us down
and because if audiences are receptive
to a quality movie believe me they don't
get it we're all just waiting to make it
and so so at that time that period about
10 12 years there every single week
there was some kind of film coming out
addressing some social issue in a
and clearly with First Reformed you have
taken on the subject and problems around
climate change as one of the things that
underpin the story I wonder how you feel
your audiences have responded to that
aspect of the story but I lost you as
climate change how do you think your
audiences have responded to that aspect
of the story well you know that's a big
question because there is no displace
there is no response we have as the
species we have made our decision and
it's pretty clear and our question of
how long it takes for that decision to
be fully effective but you know there is
no well whatever tipping point there was
we passed it and and it is you know it's
very hard to a friend of mine wrote an
article for the New York Times calling
called you know raising a child in a
doomed the world and my adult children
do not have children and they don't feel
they should and that is a question that
begins first reformed should should I
bring someone into this world knowing
what kind of life they will have and so
it'll be nice to say the movie has a
positive effect but our gorilla brains
are not gonna get us out of this problem
evolution has taken us about as far as a
camp the next stage will be some other
form of evolved intelligence but Oscar
Ella's you know we are not equipped to
solve this problem but you do have
easily
was character taller tell us that it's
better to have her well you know Albert
Camus said I don't believe I choose to
believe and you know that's where we are
I don't hope I have no reason to help
but you can't choose to hope and that
could be a way to live mm-hmm although
if we look at some of the choices in
First Reformed and go back to the Yakuza
or the suicidal tendency in in many of
your films your characters often used
suicide as a method of action and I
think you said in one of the lines in
Yakuza was that in Japan when the
character is cracking up they take it
out on themselves but in America they
open the window and take it out on
everyone else I wondered if you could
elaborate a little about that you know
always interesting couple weeks ago
someone was mean misma and I watched the
opening of it and the initial voiceover
comes from a book Southern Steel it
beats my Road and it was talking about
his decision to take this course of
action he says you know words are no
longer sufficient so I have found a new
form of expression and that new form of
expression was no prism and then 30-some
years later I'm sitting in my office I'm
writing the script first before I write
a lot and he says I have found a new
form of Prayer
oh wow that's a good life I didn't
realize I had written in 35 years so it
does all kind of circle around yeah well
it feels to me as though and first
reform really is the state of grace from
the state of nature that we discovered
you with at the beginning of your career
I could talk to you all evening that I
might
that the audience may have questions so
can I open it to the to the floor and
see if there's anything anyone here
would like Joelle spool I'm down here in
the front row I think we have mics
I thought pleasure to hear you speaking
I was wondering to just talk a little
bit about your process of writing and
how did it change at all when you
collaborate with director Martin
Scorsese for example or do you stick to
your prices throughout I'm not a very
good employee I wish I was because
there's a lot of money to be made by
being a good employee you know I wrote
four scripts for Scorsese but we never
talked about it I would do it he would
do to get but there's only one person in
the room when I was writing and the last
film we did together to bringing out the
dead I realized that we would not work
together again that was over because
there were now two directors in the room
and one of them was calling himself a
writer and the other one was sort of
pissed off and silver I realized you
know there can only be one director you
know Marcy's script about but and not
have to be him it's not me so I have not
been very good at collaborating I've
never held a job in my life I'm every
single job I've ever had I got fired
from always at some point where somebody
says do it this way and you say no not
the way you do it you do it this way and
then they say you know who's the boss
here get fired so that's really probably
the reason why I work I expect all these
years because I used to get jobs but I
always got trouble when I got a bad
reputation as somebody who was not
cooperative it was not a team player so
I realized that the only way
I can make a living to just do my own
thing and then go out and find somebody
to play that's it
but how did you behave then uncomforted
strangers when you're the writer but you
were really acting as a director and
you've got Harold Pinter and Ian McEwan
- well most scripts that I reread I even
go to the point of retyping the entire
script so that I feel full ownership
over it
so I can stand around and say oh I
remember when I wrote this I didn't
actually write this I just retyped it
but I wrote it two scripts are had that
I didn't really want to touch I'm one
with my brothers and Alison when I was
by Harold Pinter and and we were in Rome
it was a forehand or Natasha Richardson
Rupert Everett Chris Walken healthier
and Pinter script was quite elliptical
and all the actors were they wasn't
changes and I'd like to script quite a
bit and I didn't want to make changes
but of course I'm a writer and they
pressure me
so I called up Harold and I said you
know let's do it this way will you come
down from Rome and I would do two weeks
rehearsal you rehearse the first week
I'll rehearse the second week and I
won't say a thing the first week I'll
just sit in the quarter he came down and
his rehearsal method essentially was
reading and rereading and reading the
script over don't break it and at one
point that house just said to him now
Harold I'm in Venice with my boyfriend
my two children from another man are
staying with my mother in England what
is my relationship to those children's
father is he alive do I know him are we
on good terms and he'll said dagger
there I have never answered a question
like that
not going to start now read the text and
by which she simply met you read it
enough you won't answer that question
and whatever answer you have it's going
to be a better answer than anyone I can
tell you and so after he left we all
came down and I said yo Big Daddy went
back to London and let's all discuss the
scripted Chris Walken said you know I
kind of liked it the way it is and make
no changes I think there's a question
over there on the corner Paul thank you
so much for a very enlightening lecture
it's sort of helped me as a writer I
wanted to wash you about cat people
because you know what that's in looking
at the time when you made that film no
of course today everything seems to be
Murray remade left right and center how
did you interpret that I mean was it did
the studio give you a specific mandate
what was it something that you wanted to
do on your own way well it was I was
doing the field with the discovery so it
was very much a visual exercise and I
the script the original scripts have a
kind of traditional horror arc and at
the end of the script the protagonist
shoots the monster kills the monster the
old house burns down and I thought you
know I had a inspiration I said you know
what happens if instead of killing the
monster
he [ __ ] it and then he built a shrine
to it and comes and worships
wouldn't that be a boring interesting
ending and that's what we did and and I
remember we had a screening
in Westwood
and with Jerry Bruckheimer who is the
producer we were sit in the background
there's two teenage girls in front of us
and it comes to the ending when John
heard is carrying up nostalgia in the
bondage of David Bowie in toning this
sort of ritualistic music and he's tying
up the time so he can [ __ ] her to make
her back into a leopard and and the two
girls in front of you and one turns the
other and said oh my god I turned to joy
I think maybe we went but you know
looking back at it that's why he'll
probably has a shelf life because
there's not a lot of competition for
that there's a lady down here at the
front sorry those of you at the back I
can't see your hand so wave aggressively
if you have questions hello can you hear
me
yeah um well what I love about your your
films is that the scripts and lie
somewhere between cynicism without ever
being cynical and sentimentality and
they're never sentiment sentimental and
I hate that yeah that so you you get to
really human human feelings sometimes
awkward but always we can identify with
and one of the brilliant expressions of
that was in first reformed and I knew I
if I could vote for the Academy Award I
would have been this moment it was when
he's showing around the tourists the
family and he says we have a little gift
shop here and he says and I'm of any
looks at the mini says I'm afraid work
out the only thing we have left is a
small size
and knowing of course how Americans are
so obese of course that would all all
that would be left but then that the
fact that this man after all we've seen
him go through is reduced to saying that
and I just thought it was brilliant how
did you ever think well in that
particular case wardrobe you know
provided the t-shirts and being cost
effective as they were they only did
extra small because no one was going to
put them on and so the extra small looks
the same size as extra large and so I
was looking through myself these are all
extra small so we did that on the fly
but but that joke in that scene that was
the joke I heard growing up in the
church about the minister and the choir
mistress
you know she chased him around the
church and caught him by the organ and
the joke I heard as a kid finally found
a place works it's a question out there
at the back I'm hired this might be
quite a quick answer but do you ever
write different versions of scripts for
finance here's what actors do you ever
kind of change them based on who you're
kind of sending them to well I've been
the only reason you would change
requests I had a meeting two days ago
about this film I want to do with Willem
and even and the antagonist is 300 pound
Mexico and the financier said I think we
can get more money if you make the
antagonist a woman and so I'm gonna try
that and make our sort of Mercedes
McCambridge like and but and often when
someone makes a suggestion like that
it throws you for a loop but I also fire
some neurons up to anything that's you
know I can actually sort of do that but
I would never write something
specifically for an actor that that
that's the door to hell you know it
makes you a lazy writer to begin with
because you're now hearing the words as
spoken by Al Pacino and you're saying
wow that's a great speech it's not a
great speech how much he knows a good
actor that's all and so you have to try
to write the dialogue of scenes almost
act approved so that if it so happens
that the only way they'll finance that
movie is with a log of attackers you
know our singer your script should be
good enough to still work with Arnold so
that's how you have to think as a writer
it's a question down hit hello in first
formed you you shoot the movie in a
particular aspect ratio which is very
focusing and it changes at one point
later on in the film and I was wondering
about that in terms of the process of
writing the story was that something you
conceived as you wrote it how it was
going to be viewed or was that later on
as a director that you look at that no I
said this yesterday I have written a
book of theological aesthetics so
critics but I never thought I would make
a film of that nature and then about
three years ago I was having a
conversation with Ravel pavlovsky IDO
half of that conversation
I walked up town and I realize is now
time it's time for you to write that
spiritual script but when you go swore
for decades that you would never write
and either was one three three black and
white so I said okay I'm gonna do a film
just like that one three three bike away
eventually I ended up making it in color
but that was the template
and since I was dealing with spiritual
style your you'll immediately engage
yourself with withholding devices you
immediately start giving less well one
way you can give less if they have a
smaller image you know with hold music
withhold acting withhold editing you
know with home camera moves with hold
for run background and so it's just one
of a buffet of withholding devices do
you regrets that you made it in cover
what do you regret having made it in
time
no no I don't because I saw those new
film cold war and I was just talking to
him he was saying how great it was in
black I don't know I thought it should
have been a call and then you know you
can't shoot and no you can now shoot in
black and white digitally two years ago
you couldn't so a film like Nebraska was
simply shot in color and then they
dialed it down some other reasons the
black-and-white is so unattractive but
now they have a dedicated
black-and-white digital camera so you
can shoot it back away but what that
means is you can't do both you know you
have to design your set your palette
from black and white or color and so
then the task simply became how little
color can we use and how minimal can we
make everything and so you know there's
red is used for the pepto-bismol and for
the blood you know and so that becomes
one of those constraints that is very
very useful because limitations in any
art form are inspirational if I tell you
that I want you to make fiberglass
chairs
for a 500 pound person but it has to be
really stylish your your minds gonna
jump so how can I do that whereas if I
tell you I want you to make a stylish
fiberglass chair your mind isn't gonna
jump so those kinds of limitations
inspire you
it's a question Tyler you mentioning but
you need for the ending of your script
before you can start filming is that
ending dialogue or is it an actual final
visual shot so sorry I missed that
the question is down here sorry Sally
it's just so for example at the end of
blue collar where you have the
freeze-frame yeah did you decide on that
shot and that image before you wrote the
whole script cuz you're saying you need
to know the ending before you start the
writing process well you know it was
part of the script process you know when
I came to that ending in the course of
the script they probably must've been
fairly early on because I was creating a
situation that could not be resolved and
I had to just be stopped in a
dialectical way that anything was always
there you know you know it's not like
you know how he takes for the wrench
he's gonna hit Richard well he didn't
actually hit Richard no I said cut so I
knew I was gonna freeze right gentleman
over there in the front hi you mentioned
a squib that you'd abandoned recently I
just wondered have you got lots of
abandoned scripts and or has that become
rarer over your career not really
he asked about a banner script because
of this process I used I try not to
write until I know what's gonna work and
I was writing a script about my late
brother very very personal script and I
thought I had it I wrote it and I knew I
somehow it wasn't I missed it I missed
it and because it was such a personal
subject
you know it was time to put it on the
shelf and see if it comes back to life
again but I'm not gonna go in the
marketplace with something that personal
that I don't believe it that's what I do
down here in the front room hello so yes
first of all thank you for being so
entertaining as well as say helpful at
the same time and my question is kind of
a follow-up for net and I was so a
response to what you were saying about
what audiences are not interested in if
the demand was there their particular
areas that you would like to go into
that you're just kind of waiting for a
sign for like well like stories you in a
tower or subjects that you in a bridge
that it's still burning a hole inside
you well I mean yeah I talked earlier
about the problems you know what has
long long this journey
well obviously the last problem you have
is you know your own demise and I tried
to do a film about that seven years ago
and the body was taken away from me and
I disowned it called dying of the light
with Nic Cage so it's still out there I
haven't yet solved that one so maybe I
should swing back around one of the
problems with doing a film about old age
is that you know it's harder to sell
tickets because everyone wants to sell
to the younger audience so you you have
to be very very careful about that I
mean I would love to do you know I would
love to do a film about new intelligence
but again you have that same problem
it's like somebody says I'm gonna do a
film about the Neanderthals and the
cro-magnons but
and it's about how no and the Homo
sapiens dinosaurs are the hope we'll see
same P ads and how the Homo sapiens
advanced but you can only sell tickets
to the Neanderthals well hard shop it's
hard to make a movie in which the the
[Music]
the fail the film species is the one
that's watch you know there's a lady
over there on the right with the
microphone thank you thank you Paul my
quick question is have you learnt or
have you experienced from writer's block
experience of writer's block writer's
block have you had it have you know
usually with this method you don't have
because you don't start writing until
you know everything if you have so you
never stop not knowing what's gonna come
next
you know whether the secrets of writer's
block is you have always have to finish
writing for the day before you've
completely finished the scene so you
immediately jump right back in you know
where you are
the the longest period of the writer's
block I had was I used to be a night
writer and I would start about 11:00 and
write till 5:00 6:00 in the morning and
that was a kind of cascade of alcohol
nicotine caffeine cocaine and you can
get a lot of writing done
and you know there were certain spelling
errors but for the most part is quite
good and and those little people who
live inside the typewriter they need
some inducement to come out they just
don't come out on their own so you have
to give up come on out come on up and
then they did they come out and they
climb out of the typewriter start
running all around the desk then I had a
child and the idea of going to bed at
6:00 was no longer a feasible one and I
also didn't want to be in that condition
when you know my child woke up so I said
that you know it's time to become a day
writer and that took almost a year to
retrain myself I got in office and I'd
go there and I just sit and but I
refused to write at night till finally
started to copy and I could write there
in the day and now I can't even write at
night
well Paul um it's been a real pleasure
talking to you and thank you for
teaching us today and for the last
decades thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you